to Brussels now where NATO defense
ministers are meeting to discuss
boosting support for Ukraine the
alliance's Secretary General has
promised more ammunition for Kiev
we see no signs that the President Putin
is preparing for peace what we see is
the opposite he is preparing for more
war for new offensives and new attacks
so it makes it just even more important
that NATO allies and partners
provide more support to Ukraine
tell us to tell us more about what the
defense ministers have been saying is
that vassin who joins us live from
Brussels so what more support is Ukraine
going to be getting step after this
meeting
well that's a very good question it's
only three weeks ago that this so-called
Ukraine support group has been meeting
they call it also the Ramstein a format
and the U.S defense secretary Lloyd
Austin stressed again that uh that
Ukraine really needs urgent help and
that they will stand by Ukraine uh until
a very long time so basically we're
popping up support but in real life in
practicalities it's very difficult to
find a ammunition right now that's what
the Secretary General of NATO has said
they did a survey an extraordinary
survey and they found out that stocks
all around NATO are very low now so it's
not only not enough ammunition to go to
the front lines in Ukraine but also for
NATO countries which is very worrying so
today the discussion is mostly about
speeding up a production of ammunition
and also making contracts making sure
that they have enough production lines
going on for very fast so they can move
these ammunitions from the factories
immediately to the front line and the
other Hot Topic here is f-16s these
fighter jets that president zielinski
has asked for he calls them Wings of
Freedom and one of the countries who has
these f-16s they have 24 of them is the
Netherlands and I asked the defense
minister of the Netherlands what she
said to Ukraine when they asked
specifically to send these f-16s to the
front line
they're looking of course ahead and air
defense is very important to Ukraine in
this war that might drag on for for some
time so I completely understand this
request but my colleague also understand
that this is something that will take
time because we have to coordinate with
our partner countries we really have to
think through the possibilities the
consequences
well this will definitely Dash some
hopes that Ukraine might have had that
from this meeting today in Brussels
there will be a decision on these f-16s
it's been a long discussion already and
for some NATO countries it is a red line
for example for Germany and also Poland
who has f-16s has said we only do this
when we do this together with NATO so
there's a lot of division among the NATO
countries and meanwhile solderberg has
said we have to keep our promises of
sending battle tanks and ammunition
before we're going to discuss more about
these f-16s thank you for their updates
advice in life force in Brussels